let's continue the third story of the
day in case you don't think
that the modern left is racist which it
is
uh they are now uh basically stopping
the republicans
from passing a condemnation on
anti-semitism
by the way when they do all these things
we condem asian hate we condemn hatred
of jews we
condemn hatred of black people these
things are usually just lip service
right like the best way you can get
people
to fight racism is to know
you know the basics treat people
individually don't judge
by the color skin and all that stuff so
i'm not even defending the bill here in
and of itself but if you want to just
see how ridiculous this game
is played we've got some quotes from
blaze media republican senators on
tuesday
introduced a resolution to condemn the
recent rise in hateful violence
committed against american jews and
denounce poisonous rhetoric
from progressive lawmakers who have
spoken out against israel amid
renewed conflict in the middle east it
quotes for example ilhan omar calling
israeli prime minister benjamin
netanyahu an ethno-nationalist
on the floor of the house of
representatives and a tweet she sent
accusing israel of war crimes
other poisonous anti-israel rhetoric
cited
includes rashida talib's declaration
that palestinian babies children and
their parents were being massacred by
israel
and aoc's statement describing israel as
an apartheid state
and corey bush's tweet accusing israel
of ethnic cleansing
further the republicans want the senate
to reject the biased
incomplete and inaccurate information
promulgated
by the news media in the united states
about israel and the government
of israel's efforts to protect its
citizens from terrorism
so basically no democrats are going to
vote for this because the parties become
completely hysterical and there were
some tweets in the last couple days from
bernie sanders and i saw one from
elizabeth warren
where they condemn anti-semitism because
you know there's been these mobs
literally chasing jews down the street
in new york and in la and other cities
but they also equally condemn
islamophobia
now put aside why the word islamophobia
there's issues with that because
phobia is an irrational fear and islam
is an idea you don't
want to be bigoted towards people muslim
people of course you don't want to be
bigoted towards them but you're allowed
to criticize an idea
anti-semitism is about hating a specific
group of people but i get it people are
sort of lost on terms and words and all
that kind of stuff
the fact that they just couldn't condemn
the fact that there
are jews being hunted down and they had
to somehow link that to islamophobia was
there any
incidences of of muslim hate uh you know
hate crimes against muslim people in the
last week
but for some reason the people who find
racism everywhere
when hatred is against jews they have to
link it to something else
and that's very consistent with this
horrific set of ideas jews are a
minority that have succeeded and they
got to take you down
they got to take you down you uppity
jews you're just like the white people
now
and you're going to get what's coming to
you in some cases actually worse
uh it's it's a really terrible set of
ideas guys
have i not made myself clear today i
think i think i was i think it was
fairly clear about how i feel today
the democrats on the left have
completely lost their mind they are
importing racism and trying to destroy
the country
there's the quote of the day
you